جانبها اعلنت سلطات ودنيات كالمواليه
لروسيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه تواصلت قصف
المناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتها ليله الماضيه
وصباح اليوم منذ دخول الهدنه التي اعلنها
رئيس الروسي فلاديمي بوت حيزه تنفيذ
منتصفها يوم امس
الاوكرانيه قصف بالمدفع مدينه
القوه الروسيه والقوات لها تقدمها الى
احياء مدينه سردار عليه استراتيجيه في
محور بخموت وقالت من الجيش الاوكرانيه قصف
انها حصلت على معلومات تشير تلقي او تشير
الى تلقي القوات الاوكانيه اوامره عسكريه
بالانسحاب من المدينه والبلدات المحيطه
بها
وزير الداخليه
الى التروي في بث المعلومات عن المعارك في
المدينه تاما وزير الدفاع الاوكراني روسيا
بارتكاب جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا وقال انه
ليس لديها اي قطط لوقف ذلك